dr anthony fauci says the u.s could
start vaccinating high school students
against covid this fall and younger
students
early next year meanwhile president
biden is pushing to make the vaccine
available for all
teachers by the end of the month but the
cdc
cdc says that's not required for the
safe reopening of schools
meg oliver spoke with some teachers who
said they had to go back to the
classroom before
they could get vaccinated meg good
morning
anthony good morning the cdc says
vaccinations are only one way to stop
the spread in schools along with social
distancing
and masks but some unions across the
country say
not requiring them could mean teachers
won't return
the folks we spoke to said they faced a
decision either put themselves and their
families in danger
or risk losing the job they love
it's like a ghost town at peabody high
school in massachusetts
i have one student in one class today
corey manuel starts prepping his class
just before 7am
i worry about myself getting sick i
worry about
kids getting sick since going back in
december the biology teacher has been
teaching a hybrid model
spending half of his day in person and
half of his time
virtual it's not the same it's
disheartening
i can't hand out materials i can't
collect materials i can't put the desks
together in small groups
if you need to use my hand sanitizer use
it on your way in
about eight miles away at saugus middle
school good morning friends at home
and friends at school corey's wife jess
manuel
returned to room 176 last week neither
teacher had been vaccinated
how did you feel about returning in
person anxious
i was anxious about every part of it i
have a lot more anxiety than he does
did you feel like you were taking a risk
very much so why did you go back
i didn't have much of a choice it was
that or not get paid
the couple has three children learning
virtually at home
and the family lives with jess's parents
all they wanted before returning to
school
was a shot in the arm when they finally
prioritized teachers in massachusetts to
get the vaccine
what was your reaction to that finally
finally you just wanted to be vaccinated
before you went back
that's the biggest thing yes and there's
been a lot of talk of teachers
not wanting to work and not wanting to
go back to school
i can promise you that i have not
devoted 15 years of my life and i don't
have three advanced degrees in education
because i don't like kids and i don't
want to go back to school
a lot of people have said why can't
teachers go back when grocery workers
have gone back or health care workers
have gone back
even before a vaccine was developed
they're
different situations ideally everybody
should be vaccinated
it's difficult to feel like an
afterthought
when you know states are saying okay
here's the date you're going back
and then a week later okay we'll figure
out when we can get teachers vaccinated
that's a frustrating situation hi how
are you good i'm checking in
it's an emotional situation as well i'm
so excited this is like
it's a game changer three hours before
we sat down with the couple
the fact that i got here i feel like i
won the lottery we followed jess to get
her
long-awaited shot ready one
two three it's unbelievable
it's it feels like the first time i've
taken a really deep breath
in a long time sorry
this was a big day for you i really feel
like
it was this page that turn is just a
little bit shinier like there's just a
little bit more hope there
that feeling of hope continued on sunday
as you can see in this video
corey sat down for his first shot
something he has been waiting for
now we should know that since last year
puberty high school has encouraged hand
washing
social distancing and they have been
handing out ppe to teachers and students
corey says he will only send his own
children back into school
when he receives that second shot
anthony so great to see them getting
that shot and then see that relief on
their faces i know i've said it so many
times
i got a teacher at home just give the
teachers the shots
yes just give them the shots you've also
made the point that the only side effect
of the show is just gonna say that
relief and peace
they want to go back they want to be
there just get them the shots